Amanda Seyfried and Shirley MacLaine
hits the red carpet Wednesday night with
makeup and lights you look so beautiful
I mean look at faces for a long time you
are really gorgeous it was all to
support their new movie the last word
when the time comes I will be writing
her obituary I want you to write it now
great absolutely the best and I watched
their love up there and I watched the
baby almost being conceived yes Amanda's
bout to first baby bump was the real
word on the carpet Shirley was just a
gushing over how beautiful your lady
looked are you blown away by her tonight
I'm blown away without her every day she
looks about ready to pop she does she
does look about ready to pop it's a
pretty amazing thing you know I just get
to sort of hang back and watch it all
happen or just like that's that's the
great joy for me I trying to learn as
much as I possibly can and just do
whatever needs to be done and stay out
of the way not screw up too much yeah
I'm ready yeah twelve months pregnant
can you believe that can you believe it
do you know if it's a boy or girl I do I
totally know they're not gonna tell it I
guess not several yeah you gotta meet
them you gotta meet that no I mean you
have to like meet the child in order to
I think no right so you can know the
child in yourself
[Music]